[Music]  what do you recreate an assisting chapel  in this boy's room not that right  you should be knee-deep in a sofa with  some great as eyes wherever he goes I go  whatever you say officer what what's  happening it's hard give me the  defibrillator  [Music]  let me handle it  took my wife dirty cops  where you go I'm gonna kill him  [Music]  [Music]  [ __ ] hey it's a video game  Oh [ __ ] grown up man I don't play  video games yeah well maybe you should  try to help you with your aggression  scene I'll do anything for my family  this is just [ __ ] anything as it gets  but bring him to us and you'll get your  wife back you've won me over you're  going to jail you just say stupid [ __ ]  all the time I'm going to show you come  on with me pal I want back ten powers  and the remiz detail can you get the  [ __ ] out of the car please I have pepper  spray in my first they have a gun in my  pants  [Music]